we're seeing
other countries around the world begin
to say
uh i believe i believe germany i believe
denmark i believe ira uh ireland
begin to say you know what
terrible disease awful virus
we're going back to life
we're going back to normal life
because we feel that we've done what we
can do
we will
hopefully continue to treat
uh and you know i think um because of
laws in europe things like planes are
still um you'll still have people with
masks on them and such um
but for the most part life is going back
to normal even in countries uh that
continue to have covet and you know this
is a place um
you know you and i think slightly
disagree at this point back you know
when we when we publish the substance
piece that we did at the end of july
laying out what we understand to be
um our you know what we understand to be
science's current understanding with
regard to um things like um um off-label
use of you know repurposed drugs for
treatment and prophylaxis of of covid
and the vaccines and how
how universally effective a response
that can be um we said and i think even
the title of the piece was
uh you know we have to we have to get
rid of this virus we have to eradicate
that extent we have to drive it extinct
and um
i'm no longer convinced this is possible
um i'm i am convinced and um
i i think i will remain convinced that
it was possible that it was possible and
it was possible for a very long time and
that we didn't do it and it's not
because uh some part of the population
refused to comply it's because um our
policies were bad
but
given that it looks like it is an ever
more impossible target to actually
eradicate this thing and that we do live
uh with um you know far worse pathogens
things like things like rabies
things like yellow fever and it's not
that those that i'm not saying i like
those things right or that i think that
we should encourage them but that we
live with them uh
with plans in place to prophylax if we
can and to treat and to vaccinate if
it's possible and um you know the
countries that are saying enough is
enough
are
well you know let's see how how it works
for them but uh so far so good
yeah i i think in some sense the
question about whether it is possible to
drive it extinct has become
politicized and like it's not even
possible to know the answer because the
data stream is so dirty right and you
know
i'm not saying i'm convinced it's
possible i i am convinced it was
possible i have seen nothing that tells
me it isn't possible in general the
arguments that people marshal that
suggest it isn't possible are not good
arguments and i think the real important
point is it actually doesn't matter
because
if it is not possible then the obvious
objective is to control it as well as
for example we control rabies right
babies are still with us we have no
mechanism for getting rid of it however
how many people die of rabies every year
you know within the u.s for example yes
and and you know of course there's a
massive difference uh in that
uh you know rabies has a case fatality
rate close to one
i mean it is one i i i think there may
have been one case there's
one case for someone surviving
somebody survived well surviving rabies
without getting treatment very quickly
surviving rabies with onset of symptoms
you can treat rabies having been uh
infected yeah so it's not gonna be the
cfr but yes yeah at the point that you
show symptoms um it's basically a death
sentence unless uh unless you've gotten
treatment so it's a totally different
disease and yet we have figured out how
to live with it and have decreased
mortality too close to zero now we're
going to take a lot of crap for
analogizing the two because obviously
they're very different diseases
transmitted in a very different way but
nonetheless the point is complete
control of the disease has to be the
objective if extinction is out of range
and i don't think anyone actually knows
that extinction is out of range and you
know it's a discussion that we should be
having unfortunately because this is a
politicized question depending upon
whether uh
various parties are interested in
pretending that they have a plan to
drive it extinct or thwarting those who
would point out that their plan is no
good you'll hear both answers
[Music]